.
>> WISH THEM ALL THE BEST.
>> VERY EXCITED FOR THEM BOTH.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
THIS -- MAYBE THIS IS NOT SO
EXCITING FOR SOME PEOPLE.
IT'S A GROUP OF REPUBLICAN
SENATORS GOING TO THE WHITE
HOUSE LATER TODAY TO TALK WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT HIS NEARLY
$2.3 TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO FIND
COMMON GROUND AND SUPPORT FROM
THOSE REPUBLICANS.
ED O'KEEFE IS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH MORE ON THIS STORY.
ED, WE JUST TOLD YOU ABOUT TONY.
I KNOW YOU'RE EXCITED, TOO.
BUT I KNOW YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT'S AT STAKE IN THIS MEETING,
ED O'KEEFE?
>> Reporter: WAY TO SELL IT,
GOSH.
I LIKE BABIES, TOO.
THIS IS IMPORTANT NEWS BECAUSE
--
>> OKAY --
>> Reporter: HERE'S WHY -- AND
WE WISH TONY AND KATY ALL THE
BEST AS WE WAIT FOR THAT.
REASON WHY THIS MATTERS TODAY --
THIS MEETING GOING ON TODAY,
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT IN
TOWN BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
PROBABLY SET THE TONE FOR
WHETHER OR NOT WASHINGTON CAN
WORK TOGETHER, DEPENDS AND
REPUBLICANS, TO GET ANYTHING
DONE ON INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS.
IT MAY ALSO SET THE PACE OF THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THE PRESIDENT SET TO MEET WITH
THESE SIX REPUBLICAN SENATORS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SPENDING,
TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES.
THEY'LL DISCUSS THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF AN INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL
AND HOW TO PAY FOR IT.
THE PRICE TAG'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST HURDLES, AND THE
PRESIDENT'S ALREADY FACING
NOTABLE RESISTANCE FROM
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS OVER
INCREASED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
SO FAR AT LEAST 11 GOP GOVERNORS
ARE PULLING OUT OF A PROGRAM MR.
BIDEN IMPLEMENTED THAT RAISED
UNEMPLOYMENT CHECKS BY $300 A
WEEK.
THE PROGRAM IS SET TO END IN
SEPTEMBER.
BUT UNEMPLOYED WORKERS IN THESE
11 STATES WILL SEE THEIR
PAYMENTS SHRINK AS EARLY AS NEXT
MONTH.
THAT COMES AS THE MOST -- AS
MOST ECONOMISTS SAY -- SORRY
ABOUT THAT.
IT COMES AS MOST RECENT JOB
NUMBERS WERE SURPRISINGLY LOW,
JUST 266,000 JOBS WERE ADDED IN
APRIL DESPITE EIGHT MILLION JOB
OPENINGS ECONOMISTS PREDICTED
THE COUNTRY WOULD GET AT LEAST A
MILLION JOBS.
SOME ARE HAVING TROUBLE HIRING
WORKERS BECAUSE OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT MONEY, DISCOURAGING
PEOPLE FROM GOING TO WORK.
THE WHITE HOUSE DISAGREES.
WE SPOKE WITH SOME ECONOMISTS
WHO SAID THERE WERE FACTORS LIKE
VACCINATION RATES, THE LACK OF
SCHOOL OPENINGS, THE LACK OF
CHILDCARE THAT COULD BE KEEPING
PEOPLE FROM GOING BACK TO WORK.
ECONOMISTS ACKNOWLEDGE WE'RE IN
SOME PRETTY UNIQUE ECONOMIC
TIMES, THAT'S WHY THE WHITE
HOUSE WANTS TO GET THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL DONE.
IT'S ALSO WHY REPUBLICANS SAY
PERHAPS WE SHOULD BE A LITTLE
MORE MODEST IN THE SPENDING.
GOP AIDES WE SPOKE WITH SAID
THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT POANOTHER WEEK
SIGNAL IF HE'S SERIOUS ABO